welcome to this video panayotis yes is
Australia yippee tend to confuse it with
New Zealand okay Kings Indian we get
playing the classical as i did in recent
games when 92 yeah people tend to play
this this gung-ho approach yeah not
carrying about the queenside it is city
dangerous still white it gets huge
progress on the queenside but black is
okay this is not the way to go actually
taking this poll it's not it's not a
very important pawn down and black
normally goes Knight f6 back this is
dangerous for black at least
now the queenside now opens very very
quickly and I can play b6 now take on e
for those moves in all cases white has a
dangerous initiative for just one pond
and there's nowhere near getting any
play on them on the kingside going this
is the main problem you're completely
giving up on your King side ambitions
because you have your hands full with
defending the Queen side chair what does
probably be sick cm I don't I don't
actually know how to be 6 what the best
continuation is this one okay let's just
pay quickly air for a change going for
d6d six takes and I Texas my idea
cannot be really a bad move Knight c4
I'm not sure it is the best one but it's
certainly something that comes into
consideration okay cook even Queen takes
is very very logical Queen takes Queen
takes Bishop takes it's not easy for him
to keep keep material but ok let's do
this for queen bee three or Bishop c4
Bishop e6 I can take on bizhub that also
looks very shaky
and like to have two minutes out of the
clocker this is unheard of but this
looks som that all looked very very yeah
natural let's say yeah this is wins
material but how exactly i'm going to do
it take can play night f7 or Bishop
before first may start with this move
okay so if i go night f7 now he will
take before at the end i can also take
c84 for the exchange this is actually
stronger I think or easier let's say he
has to take with the night otherwise
it's a full piece I can see three Hanks
oh I'm sorry c3 hangs maybe okay let's
let's just play and not think about it
for ages um ok is Queen f7 a move to
irritate him I guess so
it's also 95 and Bishop c4 possible yeah
let's let's play that Knight takes Queen
e8 is made so he has to move the Queen
somewhere ok and now yeah maybe just
let's just take it keep it simple my 97
was strong rod 97 was was stronger
actually not okay it's not it's not
really a problem
28 5
okay um okay it's just grab it
the a pawn should be decisive 96 maybe
let's make sure that's not happening now
let's push the pawn
yeah that was a quickie game for once
that was easy I think I missed some some
things actually but the position after
black takes the pawn is really awkward
to play it's really awkward for black
check you have no no activity whatsoever
check check okay that was with check and
he's threatening here for the perpetual
so I have to cover that f3 I had to tear
to cover so is there any kind of threat
if he takes I mean let's just get the
Queen and if he takes a green takes its
on time yeah okay well the time time win
as well yeah it's really taking the pawn
it's not something i would really i
recommend it's just very very dangerous
here you can even argue a bishop before
is also a move but this is not bad for
the price of one pawn why this really
opening up the Queen side and this
assists cannot be advisable not be five
hatice's actually had also quite strong
threatening night c7 but even stronger
than my move but it's it's keeping
keeping huge pressure so it shouldn't be
bad at all now just one pawn what the
position is fantastic and after that yes
it's a win already nutsy force is also
strong but here that now I'm making a
mistake that this is a mistake I what I
did not see is I was not seeing that in
this line he can take on c3 and this is
he can take instead of this he can take
with the rookie I'm and this position is
not great actually I made a big mistake
with nine
aid I have to do this first and this is
yeah this is disastrous but i played
this is sam like it took a moment but i
saw it too late i saw it at the end of
it yeah when when I actually had played
it that rook c8 is possible but he took
here and now everything is in order
again yeah here night c7 was a what's
interesting yeah this is check very nice
he has this move though it's not so
clear yeah this is ok it just winds very
comfortably yeah it's very important I
mean even if you're not playing the
Kings Indian they are taking pawns on
the side where you are you're weaker
where the opponent has the advantage in
space and the initiative it's very often
firing yeah I'm coming back at you
because the opening of the position is
more important than this in this pawn
here White's play progresses in a very
very quick way and yeah it's it's no fun
young to be offending all the time for
just one pawn ok thanks for watching